[Music]
democracy is really in crisis as well
you know
I think that I was born into a
generation of disillusionment quite
understandably you know that I like most
people my age know politicians to be
self-serving lying ambitious thoughtless
people not public servants as they are
designed to be as they are supposed to
be and I think you know to to get out of
here
we have to reinvest faith in democracy
you know when you look around the world
that you know I've been to I've been to
Burma where people are dying every day
for fighting for democracy for the right
to vote for their right you know to for
their democratically elected leader to
be got it let out of prison you know and
and here we just we can't be bothered
you know it takes it takes a half an
hour to show up and do that so it's I
think that you know we need to we need
to bother for the whole world sake not
just our country
I figure all music is a path to joy you
know even the dark stuff
it's a longer path
[Music]
I don't mind waiting in line no I don't
mind if the bills pile up and the work
is slow I don't mind gasps oh the girls
trees all the grind
[Music]
don't mind stoner waiter or the poor
Lecoq folk don't mind
Little Miss Kitty knucklehead
[Music]
I don't mind if every last person here
is ugly err
[Music]
attitude
with you
be stuck in traffic forever away
Quinta
currency
could be flaming Christmas trees and be
smile
[Music]
I don't mind waking up early for flight
that's delayed
don't mind
vacation was chilly and red
don't mind the traffic cops are
[Music]
I don't mind
Sanda my white shirt
that twinge when I walk in that me that
I heard
I don't mind
stealing back of my hair getting
[Music]
with you
could be stuck in traffic
see
could be
Christmas tree and I abused my
[Music]
thanks so much banana nursery years
you